I'm guessing no matter who you're
supporting this November you will agree
this election is the worst but
luckily the second debate we all got to
meet Ken Bone ken mode cookie fluttered
mustachioed undecided machine who stole
the Internet's heart and then made love
to it sweetly in honor of this
civic-minded build-a-bear we played the
hashtag game ken Bohn facts for instance
did you know that if ken Bohn unfurled
his mustache dwarf the wingspan of a
bald eagle that's right Laura so uh we
tracked down the man himself on skype
got to chat with ken Bohn he is goddamn
delightful and we got him to choose his
favorite fact just for you ladies
gentlemen ken bow thanks grace it was a
real thrill to see ken Bohn facts
trending on Twitter on Monday night I
loved every one of them but I can't pick
my favorite because I'm undecided so
we're going to read a few of the best he
can't attend an ugly sweater party
because they all look so good on him duh
the Illuminati comes to him for advice
on what to do yep I actually got a
conference call with jay-z and Beyonce
after this he is the fifth golden girl
hello and here's one of the original
cast photos
clowns tweet about ken Bohn side also
true but if I ever seen one of them I'm
gonna go Liam Neeson on their ass Ken's
hugs create such dangerous levels of
euphoria they had to be regulated by the
FDA no that's actually true you should
not operate heavy machinery after you
snuggle with me thanks so much Chris and
I just want to encourage everybody to
get out there and register to vote
because in 2016 yes we can oh by the way
before we get off the bone train someone
on Twitter sent me this the sexy ken
Bohn outfit for halloween so naturally I
had to ask Ken what he thought about it
you know chris i did see the sexy ken
Bohn costume and while i was strangely
aroused i want to point out that there's
only one real sexy ken Bohn outfit out
there I'm wearing it yes sexy Kimbo the
real sexy can loan
get out there and vote everyone thank
you ken Bohn for being wonderful